he's like a mini Yanis there's a freight
train in the open floor
700 spot filling the straight line drive
and you see Kauai here just bigger and
stronger and more patient and then able
to get all the way I think Toronto is
comfortable with them Beach shooting
from the outside and settling at times
Leonard swears tax the finish and then
another strong drive to his spot creates
the early letter letter on a perfect
setup final hour gets the opportunity
gives Leonard on an island Leonard
Mariana [ __ ] ranged over but it's
one-on-ones it's a fade and he makes it
look so easy
reminding everybody of
is one of the best in the world
Lenard looking to weave his way I'm
Leonard great paces here
improve handle as good a finish it as we
have a machine that they could get some
others involved here with Philadelphia
Raj Leonard gets inside and it's just
effortless right now for Kawhi Leonard
it's cup you know one of those reasons
you don't get a lot of post play from
say a Jimmy quarter is Simmons an MP
really take up all that space down there
36 now for
said he wanted to play more in this
second round
I remember the rappers are going to
involve him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Lenard the closeout by Harris
Leonard turns house it's stuck on
automatic an elite basketball player
questions been answered here tonight
we're down to 420 to play here in the
fourth head and shoulder fake hangs the
45 for Kawhi Leonard ed said in time
great free-throw line covered he
couldn't turn the corner contestant
Leonard sticks it when you live with
that
Hawaii Leonard his first field goal
attempt it's a deuce for Leonard
Toronto's lowest scoring total in a
quarter of 16 with the scoop to the hoop
Kawhi Leonard grown man move by Kawhi
you can see then the not wanting to take
a chance they're picking up that second
foul just trying to go vertical search
gives it to kawatte the wide watch it's
a break
[Applause]
[Music]
Leonard from mimic Oh
there defensively and elastic
three-on-one developing leathery gives
it up no takes advantage gets in
transition and Kauai getting the crowd
back in it
Leonard against Simmons
[Music]
really difficult shot Leonard watch how
he creates his space and able to shoot
that I'll see how come
Phil it gets back defensively get it
inside yo soy good matchup here and
switch to get it one fake watch his feet
backs off
splash can't got him Leonard its
physical with edits nine to shoot
winner hangs catch it to go off balance
delivery Kawhi Leonard just being
patient led the defense clear taking the
hit and still the shrimp silly on the
verge of being swept now all of a sudden
this thing gets really interesting gets
the deuce plus one determined not to let
this Raptors Dean fall by the wayside
Leonard gets it in for Lauer croci Occam
the push off box out
and the foul Kawhi Leonard near on the
offensive glass to Rommel not a team
known Raptors leads a series one game to
none runner tried the crossovers the
Simmons didn't fight
Leonard leaves have the ability to take
this hit and still be able to finish
through the contact as good as you're
going to see in our league
Kawhi Leonard Lee now here's Kawhi
Leonard - are they driving attacking
over Simmons the power move by Leonard
he's got 11 I'd like to see Kobe ride to
a detail about your preparation for the
game it's a thing of beauty he doesn't
have that much detail as Leonard with
the left hand
claw don't let it dribble penetration at
the ability to pause the basketball and
finish we're in Philadelphia sit with a
dr. Jay big Tom hands Jimmy Butler
having a terrific all-around first nap
Leonard falling away Connie Ennis trying
to guard go a Leonard quick spin gets
inside and throws it down but for your
star guy to miss toughen playing a lot
of games as Leonard wide drop
Leonard little crossover sets up at work
the Leonard six to shoot looking for
some room ho three Sixers were out of it
Leonard rip this is just great
individual shot matey
pretty much helpless that time against
Harris siakam double handoff to the fly
Leonard rising up in the paint and
that's his first field goal of the game
he that was a smart move low kicks it
out to Ennis and led her to running it
back good ball fake on Simmons and Kawhi
Leonard with his first three-pointer of
the game after doing Leonard out top his
team up by five Oh Godfrey on the
baseline and punches at home well what
he did was on the hesitation it just
throws Simmons
he just stopped keep an eye on Kauai
here and there's your hesitation just
blew right by Simmons all he could do is
just watch see it there it is there now
oh you can't do that breath this playing
off Gasol at the ltos Leonard into the
paint great fake and goes under for the
layup
why Leonard now with 17 in the game deaf
he played most of the game in the paint
now he's all over this is the time of
the year that he's been waiting for
Kawhi Leonard like he's doing a drill
out there James Ennis continues to
contribute in a big way off the bench
Leonard a guarded by Simmons baseline
pull-up for
well is still hot in Ibaka for the
Raptors and feed got picked off
Butler picked up Leonard it didn't
matter Kawhi Leonard drills another
jumper and the Raptors lead by four
[Applause]
switches fires along Kauai not 39 total
points lead able to just pick and beads
pocket there
kicks it ahead to Powell who finds Kauai
as he gets his first deuce of the game 7
Oh in fast-break attempts for Toronto 9
for Philadelphia looks like a different
shot off the game clock letters what's
defenders the lunging deuce for Kawhi
Leonard peeks at the clock 5 seconds
what makes it smooth they got 13 and 10
with three assists and one emphatic
finish up over the top of a 16 right now
that is trying to survive on the road
they outscore the 76ers 37 to 17 and
another kauai light that Jen 1760 in
this game just loves the big stage and
he's been a highlight machine in the
postseason the latest one from Leonard a
scow finds Kauai attacking on buckler's
and just a strong Beast move by Kawhi
Leonard and it's a 7o run since a
timeout Leonard just stepped is it out
of the air with his left hand then takes
it with his right blazing
nothing run by Toronto the shot clock at
four and a skip by Leonard Lowry great
save as he was falling Leonard takes it
all the way for the slam but boy they're
starting to dig in on the defensive end
Kyle Lowry laying out the claw coming at
you
how'd you like to be staring this in the
face butter keeps the dribble against
Simmons with a timer now at three goes
into the paint hangs and finishes with
one hand since I took over look at Co I
just dancing with the basketball a
little bit he's your clerk put this be
their last games as members of the
Sixers his letter takes it to the rim
boy he got bumped and he lost his
balance and he still hoped it Elvia does
I mean I have no idea what to think
about gm7 the way this series is gone
when he's to 1 billion looks like the
Sixers are on their way as Leonard
cleanse and then the Raptors win the
next two including them as one of the
finals MVP back with San Antonio in
details that's the advantage for I
understand they look let's get something
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody's a little tight you see fly
there just with the sleight-of-hand gets
the steal and gets out of the open floor
three triples force two Adelphia
[Applause]
and he converts at the other end for the
Raptors in Game seven
Paris defends on the perimeter
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
play green number two watch this post
entry they're just nice job you notice
the weak side help to it M be late
[Applause]
fifteen fourth-quarter points by Kawhi
Leonard
and that game-winner 41 points
[Applause]
fifteen fourth-quarter points by Kawhi
Leonard
here if you're filling it's off the
Leonard defended by Simmons is this
[Applause]